Alles klar, ist schon passiert. Gut, ich denke Sie können jetzt anfangen.
Danke schön. Ich heiße Mustafa Tabakçı. Ich bin heute Ihr zuständiger Arzt.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Kursumatlas, zuerst brauche ich Ihre Praktischen Daten und dann kommen wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Falls Sie etwas nicht verstanden haben, bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid.
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Melanie Goldstein.
Melanie Goldstein. Ja, könnten Sie bitte mir Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam ustabieren?
Melanie schreibt sich M-E-L-A-N-I-E, Melanie.
Und Goldstein schreibt sich G-O-L-D-S-T-E-I-N, Goldstein.
Frau Goldstein?
Ja.
Richtig. Wie alt sind Sie? Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren? Bitte Mittag und Monat.
Am 21. Juli 1965.
65, ja. Vielen Dank. Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,72 Meter groß und wiege 72 Kilo.
72 Kilo schwer.
Ja.
Frau Goldstein, was führt Sie heute zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich habe seit drei Stunden sehr starke, plötzlich aufgetretene Kopfschmerzen.
Seit drei Stunden.
Ja, als ob der ganze Kopf platzen wollte. So stark sind die.
Ja, mir ist schwindelig, mir ist übel. Ich habe auch dreimal erbrochen.
Dreimal erbrochen. Ja, ich verstehe Sie. Das muss unangenehm für Sie sein.
Ja, aber machen Sie keine Sorgen. Wir werden unser Bestes für Sie tun.
Okay.
Sie sind Ihre Kopfschmerzen zum ersten Mal aufgetreten oder hatten Sie ein...
Ja, sowas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Zum ersten Mal. Ja, ich verstehe.
Sie haben schon gesagt plötzlich.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen anhaltend?
Ja, sind dauernd.
Ja, dauernd.
Sie haben schon gesagt am ganzen Kopf.
Schaden Ihre Schmerzen irgendwo aus? Zum Beispiel Ihr Nacken?
Nein.
Ja.
Können Sie mir genau beschreiben, Ihre Schmerzen?
Der Schmerz ist dumpf.
Dumpf.
Dumpf. Ja.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala?
7 bis 8.
Das sind sehr starke Schmerzen.
Können Sie bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Ich hoffe. Ich hoffe, ja.
Ja, es wäre besser.
Haben Sie bemerkt, gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für die Kopfschmerzen?
Ich habe keine Erklärung dafür.
Die kamen ziemlich schnell, waren ziemlich plötzlich da.
Und ich habe keine Erklärung. Kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Haben Sie vor dem Auftreten von Ihren Schmerzen etwas Besonderes bemerkt?
Zum Beispiel komisches Geruch und Bauchschmerzen?
Nein.
Entschuldigung.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ja, so.
Gibt es etwas, was Ihre Kopfschmerzen verstärkt?
Zum Beispiel Licht oder Laut?
Ich möchte mich am liebsten ganz ruhig hinsetzen oder hinlegen.
Bewegung ist nicht so gut.
Lautstärke, Lärm, Licht auch nicht so gut.
Aber nicht so entscheidend.
Wichtig ist für mich, dass ich mich körperlich wenig bewege,
weil es sind so starke Schmerzen.
Verstärken Sie sich Ihre Schmerzen bei Bewegung?
Kann man sagen.
Kann sein, aber ich habe mich gar nicht getraut,
gar nicht gewagt, mich groß zu bewegen, weil es so wehtut.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas unternommen, Medikament eingenommen?
Nein, ich habe nur einen kalten Waschlappen,
ein Handtuch, ein kaltes Handtuch auf die Stirn gelegt.
Vielleicht, aber dadurch bin ich nicht besser.
Sie haben schon am ganzen Kopf.
Ja.
Wo?
Über Ihrem Kopf.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Ich habe hohen Blutdruck seit 5 Jahren.
Ja, das habe ich.
Ich messe den hin und wieder mal.
Zuletzt habe ich ihn, glaube ich, gemessen vor 5 Tagen.
Da war er eigentlich ganz gut.
Da war er zwischen 135, 140, zu 90.
100?
135.
Zwischen 135 und 140, zu 90 war er zuletzt vor 5 Tagen.
Sind Ihre Blutdruck gut eingestellt, kann man sagen.
Bis jetzt gab es da keine Probleme.
Ja, ich habe das akustisch nicht gehört.
135, ja.
135 zu 90.
Alles klar.
Ja, genau.
Alleine sind unter anderem Beschwerden.
In Verbindung mit dem Kopfschmerz, meinen Sie?
Ja, ja.
Ja, ich kann nicht so richtig gut sehen.
Mein Sehen ist etwas verschwommen.
Ja, ich habe Übelkeit, Erbrechen.
Sehr stark.
Und auch leider unter Hörstörung?
Nein, Hörstörung nicht.
Leider unter Nackenstäffigkeit?
Glaube ich nicht, nein.
Sind Ihnen Taubhausgefühl, Kribbeln am Bein oder am Fuß aufgefallen?
Nein, nein.
Leider unter Lähmungen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich kann alles so weit bewegen.
Ich notiere mir an die Notis.
Frau Gotstein, haben Sie Veränderungen beim Wasserlassen?
Stuhlgang bemerkt?
Nein, nichts.
Ich habe auch keine Probleme mit.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Ich hatte früher einen Reizdarm.
Aber seitdem ich das weiß, halte ich eine Diät ein,
meide bestimmte Nahrungsmittel und dann geht es besser.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Fieberstürfrust, Nachschweiß?
Nein.
Leiden Sie unter Halserasen, Halsklopfen?
Hatten Sie Schwindel?
Ja, ich habe schon gesagt Schwindel.
Haben Sie Bewusstsein verloren?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Glaube ich nicht, nein.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall am Kopf verletzt?
Nein, kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Ich hatte keinen Unfall.
Leiden Sie unter Atemnothüsten?
Nein.
Fühlen Sie sich müde, schwach?
Ja, mit den Schmerzen fühle ich mich beeinträchtigt.
Sonst habe ich mich fit gefühlt.
Vor 3 Stunden ging das los.
Vor 3 Stunden.
Leiden Sie unter Schlafstörungen?
Ja, schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut, ja.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
In Ordnung.
Haben Sie ungewohnt Gewicht abgenommen?
Nein.
Füllen Sie sich normal gestresst oder niedergeschlagen?
Ich habe keine Probleme zurzeit.
Frau Goldstein, haben Sie eine Reise in der letzten Zeit gemacht?
Ja, ich habe Reisen gemacht.
Ich war in Frankreich, ich war in Polen und ich war in Schweden.
Aber immer nur einige Tage.
Haben Sie etwas Besonderes erlebt?
Nein.
Wann war Ihre Monatsblutung?
Ich habe keine Monatsblutung mehr, seit ungefähr 5 Jahren habe ich keine Perioden mehr.
Oh ja, ich verstehe.
Frau Goldstein, Sie haben schon gesagt, Bruthochdruck und Reisleim aber mit der Diät gut behandelt.
Leiden Sie auch außer dieser Krankheit an eine chronische Krankheit?
Ich habe noch, was den Damen anbelangt, eine Milchzuckerunverträglichkeit.
Milchzucker.
Und auch das geht unter Diät sehr gut, viel besser.
Seit 2 Jahren ist bei mir bekannt ein grüner Star, auf beiden Augen, grüner Star.
Seit 2 Jahren. Da muss ich auch jeden Tag Tropfen nehmen.
Grüne Star, ja. Sie sind verwandelt, tropfen.
Ich nehme Tropfen gegen den grünen Star, regelmäßig.
Ich verstehe. Wurdest du schon mal operiert?
Ja, ich bin schon mal operiert worden. Als Kind war ich 9 Jahre alt an den Mandeln.
Und mit 11 Jahren am Blinddarm.
Und vor 4 Jahren, also da war ich 56 Jahre alt, da hatte ich einen Nierenstein.
Nierenstein auf der linken Seite. Das war sehr schmerzhaft.
Dieser Nierenstein wurde mit einer Schlinge durch die Blase entfernt.
Nierenstein. Wegen Nierenstein eine Operation mit dieser Schlinge.
Also der Bauch wurde nicht aufgeschnitten, aber es ging durch die Harnblase.
Durch die Schlinge.
Was haben Sie noch?
Das ist an chronischen Erkrankungen alles.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja. Mit dem Blutdruck nehme ich 2 verschiedene Mittel ein.
Der eine heißt Metopolol.
Wie hoch ist die Dose?
Da steht 25 hinter.
25?
Da nehme ich 2 Tabletten. Einer morgens, einer abends.
Dann nehme ich noch einen Valsatan. Da hinter steht 5.
Da nehme ich auch 2 Tabletten pro Tag. Einmal morgens, einmal abends.
Bei Bedarf?
Nein, nicht bei Bedarf. Regelmäßig.
Ich meine, nehmen Sie bei Bedarf andere Medikamente ein?
Nein, ich nehme sonst noch Augentropfen. T-Moptol.
Wie heißt das Medikament?
T-Moptol. T-Moptol. Und da nehme ich 2x am Tag 2 Tropfen.
Nehmen Sie noch anderes?
Sonst nichts.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Milchzuckerunverträglichkeit.
Allergie.
Ich habe noch Allergie in der Eimer gegen Kiwi.
Kiwi und dann Nickel.
Nickelallergie. Wenn ich z.B. einen Gürtel trage mit Nickel, dann bekomme ich einen Hautausschlag.
Ja, und dann eben Milchzuckerunverträglichkeit. Kiwi, Nickel, Milchzucker.
Ja. Beim ersten Kiwi, wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Bei Kiwi bekomme ich Ausschlag im Mund. Bläschen und das brennt. Das ist nicht angenehm.
Sie sind vorstellig, Frau Augustein?
Ich glaube ja. Ich gehe regelmäßig zu meiner Hausärztin und die überprüft das.
Die macht die notwendigen Impfungen. Sagt sie für Europa. Die habe ich alle.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich trinke so mal ein Glas Wein am Wochenende, vielleicht mal zwei Glas Wein am Wochenende.
Ein bis zwei Glas. Mehr nicht.
Am Wochenende.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, wenn ich Zeit habe, dann jogge ich. Zweimal die Woche, so ungefähr immer 30 Minuten.
Ja, das ist gut für unsere Gesundheit.
Haben Sie schon mal Drogen konsumiert?
Nein.
Frau Gottstein, sind Ihre Eltern gesund oder leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Mein Vater ist 88 Jahre alt. Der hat ausgeprägte Herzschwäche. Das Herz pumpt nicht mehr richtig.
Er hat Alterszucker. Meine Mutter ist auch 88 Jahre alt. Sie hatte vor 23 Jahren Darmkrebs.
Sie wurde operiert und bekam Chemotherapie. Aber der geht es gut.
Darmkrebs. Und 50 Jahre alt.
65. Im Alter. Und dann hat sie noch schwere Arthrose. Besonders an den Händen und an beiden Knien.
Dann hat sie noch Arthrose.
Ja, Arthrose.
Dann habe ich noch eine Schwester. Die ist ein Jahr jünger als ich. Und die Schwester hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Und die Schwester hat auch diesen Reizdarm.
Reizdarm. So. Frau Gottstein, arbeiten Sie noch?
Ja, ich arbeite noch. Ich bin Programmiererin.
Sind Sie damit mit Ihrer Arbeit zufrieden?
Ja.
Okay. So. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, bin verheiratet.
Sie wohnen mit Ihrer Familie?
Mit meinem Mann zusammen. Wir haben keine Kinder.
Keine Kinder.
Keine Kinder, ja.
Ja.
Ja, vielen Dank für ausführliche Informationen. Ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, was kann ich haben? Was ist das? So etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt. Und das tut so weh im Kopf.
Ja, ich kann Ihre Sorgen gut sehen. Aber es ist aktuell noch zu früh, eine genaue Diagnose zu stellen.
Ja.
Aber nach Ihren Angaben habe ich einen Verdacht auf Migräne oder andere.
Okay. Gut.
Aber ich brauche weitere Untersuchungen.
Okay. Gut, das können wir so machen. Danke.
Sie haben jetzt etwas Zeit, die Begriffe der Patientensprache zu überschreiben in Fachsprache.
So Begriffe wie Übelkeit, Erbrechen und so weiter. Schwindel.
Und Kollegen, die haben vielleicht noch Fragen.
Ich würde fragen, wie ist Ihr aktueller Blutdruck? Können wir das messen bitte?
Ich möchte den aktuellen Blutdruck messen.
Können wir machen. Das können wir gleich nochmal besprechen.
Dass das Sinn macht, wahrscheinlich den Blutdruck aktuell zu messen.
Richtig. Betalparameter. Das ist gut. Ja. Können wir gleich nochmal kurz diskutieren.
Ja. Okay.
Weitere Fragen? Ergänzungsfragen?
Frage Goldstein. Sagen Sie mir bitte, ob Sie über Erbrechen etwas sagen. Wie sieht das Erbrochen aus?
Das Erbrochene. Das Erbrochene, das ist so schleimig, schleimig gelblich gewesen.
Und das bedeutet? Etwas Rest vom Frühstück.
Kein Blut dabei. Hab ich nicht gesehen. Blut hab ich nicht gesehen.
Danke.
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, zum ersten Mal solche starke Schmerzen. Aber haben Sie vielleicht früher leichte Kopfschmerzen?
Ich hatte früher schon mal Kopfschmerzen. Aber das ist schon lange her. Und das ist irgendwie gar kein Vergleich mit dem Kopfschmerz jetzt.
Okay. Tragen Sie keine Brille oder keine Augenprobleme?
Ich trage eine Brille, wenn ich Bildschirmarbeit mache als Programmiererin. Dann habe ich so eine Bildschirmprille.
Okay. Super. Ich frage. Hat das geholfen?
Die Brille? Die Brille wurde mir empfohlen am Arbeitsplatz vom Betriebsarzt. Und der Augenarzt hat die dann aufgeschrieben. Und das geht ganz gut mit der Brille.
Ich bin abends nicht so ganz so müde mit den Augen.
Super. Danke.
Ja. Wenn sonst keine Fragen sind, dann lasse ich den Kollegen noch zwei, drei Minuten in Ruhe, dass er sich konzentrieren kann.
Ich sehe hier gerade eine im Chat Augen Notfall.
Ja.
Auch das kommt in unsere Differentialdiagnose mit rein. Die Nackensteifigkeit wurde gefragt von dem Kollegen. So ein Nacken ist in Ordnung.
Keine Schmerzen, wohl keine Steifigkeit.
Haben Sie auch Atemnot?
Nein. Kein Herzklopfen, kein Atemnot. Der Schmerz begann ja ziemlich plötzlich.
Manche Kopfschmerzen bauen sich langsam auf.
Dazu zählt wahrscheinlich auch der Spannungskopfschmerz eher, dass er sich langsam aufbaut und nicht so sehr plötzlich eintritt.
Zumindest habe ich das so in Erinnerung.
Könnten Sie bitte Sehstörungen ein bisschen erklären?
Wie bitte?
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Sehstörungen ein bisschen erklären?
Ich habe jetzt nicht verstanden, was Sie meinten.
Sie haben gesagt, habe ich Sehstörungen. Sehstörungen.
Sehstörungen. Sehstörungen. Ja, ich sehe verschwommen.
Ich sehe nicht ganz klar. Sonst sehe ich immer ziemlich klar. Aber seitdem ich jetzt diese Kopfschmerzen habe, sehe ich etwas verschwommen.
Also ich sehe nicht richtig scharf. So etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Den Blutdruck habe ich nach den Schmerzen nicht gemessen. Nein.
Die Schmerzen kamen relativ schnell und waren so stark, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht, jetzt den Blutdruck zu messen.
Gut, ich komme gleich sofort wieder und dann versuchen wir den Fall zu lösen. Gemeinsam.
Die Aktionen sind unabhängig, nicht wahr? Wir müssen sie nicht kaputt machen.
Ich glaube, du kannst die Klappe aufschneiden.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, deswegen wollte ich sie fragen.
Wir werden sie dann auf den Puls aufschneiden.
Ich halte sie auf.
Ja, ja.
Frau Goldstein stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit drei Stunden aufgetretenen,
die Schmerzen würden mit Vertigo, 3 Malige Amazis und 3 Malige Amazis einhergehen.
Die Schmerzen würden sich beim Sefallier, die Schmerzen würden sich beim Hinsetzen und Unruhe linden.
Die Patienten erwähnten, dass sie auch Photophobie und Phonophobie haben.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber ...
Sie haben das gefragt oder es wurde gefragt. Sie weiß es nicht genau, aber sie möchte Ruhe haben. Ruhe ist das Beste.
Wie ist der Schmerzcharakter noch einmal? Können Sie den Schmerzcharakter sagen?
Die Qualität?
Dumpfer Schmerz.
Und welche Stärke?
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 7 bis 8 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Die Patienten haben gegen diese Schmerzen kalte Handtücher verwendet, aber das hat keine Linderung gebracht.
Laut der Patienten seien solche Schmerzen zum ersten Mal aufgetreten.
Begleitend klagte die Patientin auch eine verschwimmene Sechsstörung.
Sie können sagen, die Patientin klagt über Visusstörung. Das ist allgemein. Mehr muss man gar nicht sagen. Sie kann nicht mehr richtig klar sehen.
Man könnte noch fragen, ob sie Doppelbilder haben. Doppelbilder wohl nicht, aber sie kann nicht scharf sehen. Dann können Sie sagen Visusstörung.
Das ist unaufwendig.
Hat die Patientin Fieber?
Kein Fieber.
Kein Fieber, ok.
Die Patienten haben keine Fieber.
Die Fragen nach Hypostese, Parastese, Paralysie, Mixion, Fieber, Schüttelflut, Nachschweiß, kardiologische Symptome, pulmonologische Symptome wie Thustis und auch Dyspne.
Gewichtveränderung.
Und würden verneint.
Ok.
Die Reiseanamnese sei keine relevant.
Sei unauffällig.
An der Operation für Erkrankung leiden die Patienten an arteriöler Hypertonie seit 5 Jahren.
In den letzten Zeiten haben die Patienten ihren Blutdruck gemessen.
Der letzte gemessene Blutdruck liegt bei 135 zu 90.
Vor 5 Tagen.
Was hat die Patientin sonst noch für chronische Erkrankungen?
Der Patient, der Außerirdem, ein Reisderms-Syndrom.
Ja, Colon Irritable, kann man vielleicht sagen.
Colon Irritable.
Reisderms-Syndrom.
Aber laut der Patienten sei die Colon Irritable mit einem bestimmten Diet gut kontrolliert.
Gut kontrolliert, ja.
Und was hat die Patientin noch?
Außerirdem erwähnt die Patienten Laktosintoleranz.
Ok.
Aber Laktosintoleranz, diese Krankheit sei auch mit dem Diet.
Mit der Diet ist sie ganz gut beherrschbar eingestellt.
Was gibt es noch an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Chronischen Erkrankungen.
Der Patient hat nicht ...
Warum nimmt die Patientin Augentropfen?
Ah ja, sorry.
Glaukom.
Also grüner Star, die Patientin hat grüner Star.
Ok.
Jetzt passiert auch leider ...
Ja, an Glaukom. Seit wann? Wie lange schon?
Seit zwei Jahren.
Was gibt die Patientin gegen diese Erkrankungen für Medikamente ein?
Ja.
Die Patienten nehmen gegen arteriale Hypertonie Metoprolol 25 mg zweimal täglich.
Ok.
So wie Balzartan 5 mg zweimal täglich.
Balzartan? Nein.
Ja, euch ist richtig.
5 mg. Aber das ist falsch.
Ja? Gibt es das nicht?
Balzartan, wenn ich richtig weiß, entweder 80 mg oder
Das kann sein. Da habe ich das falsch geschrieben.
Dann stimmt das, was Sie sagen. 80 mg.
Nehmen wir 80 mg.
80. Ja ok, 80 mg.
Ok. Und was nimmt die Patientin?
Augentropfen, Timoptol. Nehmen wir Timoptol zweimal täglich.
Nehmen wir Timoptol zweimal gegen Glaukom.
Ja, zweimal zwei Tropfen.
Hat die Patientin Operationen hinter sich?
Ja. An Operationen sind beide Patienten vorhanden.
Im Alter von 9 sei bei der Patientin eine Tonsillektomie durchgeführt worden.
Im Alter von 11 sei der Patientin eine Appendiktomie durchgeführt worden.
Und auch vor zwei Jahren wurde bei der Patientin eine, ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber eine Stanz.
Eine Schlinge.
Eine Schlinge wegen Nierenstein.
Ja, es war wohl ein Harnleiterstein. Was würden Sie sagen?
Ureter?
Ja, Harnleiterstein.
Der Stein wurde mittels einer Schlinge im Rahmen einer Zystoskopie geborgen.
Ok.
Eingeführt, ja.
Ja. Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familienvorgeschichte?
Ja.
Der Vater sei 88 Jahre alt und leidet an Herzinsuffizienz, vorgeschrittener Herzinsuffizienz.
Oder Myokatinsoffizienz.
Ja, Herzinsuffizienz, Myokatinsoffizienz.
So wie Diabetes mellitus, Typ 2.
Ok.
Ja, der Mutter habe einen Kolonkarsinum.
Wann war das?
Kolonkarsinum gelitten im Alter von 56 Jahren.
65 Jahren.
Ja, bei ihm eine Operation durchgeführt.
Und was noch zusätzlich zur Operation?
Und auch, ja, der Mutter auch, habe Osteoarthrose.
Ok, Polyarthrose oder Arthrose und besonders Kniearthrose.
Kennen Sie den Begriff Kniearthrose?
Kniearthrose?
Ja, in den Knien. Arthrose in den Kniegelenken. Wie heißt das? Medizinisch.
Ja.
Darf ich sagen?
Ja, sagen Sie.
Gonarthrose.
Jetzt bin ich wieder bei der Hüftarthrose. Kennen Sie den Begriff der Hüfte?
Kuchtharthrose.
Sehr häufige Diagnosen. Ich sage es mal wieder.
Kuchtharthrose, Gonarthrose. Ok.
Gut, ja prima.
Dann würde ich Sie jetzt mal fragen, was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstdiagnose?
Ja, eigentlich habe ich zuerst einen Migrant gedacht, aber nach den anamnischen Angaben
hieß es auf eine hypertensive Krise.
Was gibt es denn noch? Was könnte noch einen akuten, relativ schnell beginnenden Kopfschmerz?
Ja, aus Diffusiondiagnosen kommen subarachnode Blutung in Betracht.
Genau, das wurde von einer Kollegin da auch schon erwähnt eben. Da muss man daran denken, an einen relativ starken Kopfschmerz.
Manchmal können die Patienten das gar nicht genau lokalisieren.
Oft ist es ja mehr so an der Schädelbasis vielleicht, aber ich glaube, wenn die Patienten richtig starke Kopfschmerzen haben,
dann wird das schwierig und sie noch vielleicht auch ansprechbar sind.
Aber man muss an eine SAB auch denken.
Ja, in der Regel würde die Kopfschmerzen mit Nackensteifigkeit bei subarachnode Blutung erwecken.
Vielleicht würden Sie das dann bei der körperlichen Untersuchung doch noch kündigen, dass vielleicht doch eine gewisse Nackensteifigkeit da ist.
Sie haben ja bisher nur die Patientin befragt. Sie haben ja nur Fragen gestellt.
Jetzt haben wir noch eine dritte Komplex, weshalb die Patientin auch ein Medikament nimmt.
Das dürfen wir zumindest nicht außer Acht lassen. Glawom.
Es könnte durchaus ein Glawom-Anfall sein, der nicht immer nur so einseitig ist.
Das kann auch manchmal sehr diffuse Kopfschmerzen machen und starke Kopfschmerzen.
Zumindest sollte man das differenzial diagnostisch bedenken.
Das ist jetzt ein Glawom-Anfall, ist für die Patientin nicht vital bedrohlich, wie eine subarachnodal Blutung oder wie eine hypertensive Krise.
Die kann natürlich auch mit einer Rolle spielen.
Also ich würde Ihnen erstmal vielen Dank. Ich habe Sie gut verstanden.
Sie haben sehr viele Fachbegriffe. Können Sie die können Sie auch einsetzen.
Das ist gut. Es geht ja um die Fachspracheprüfung.
Es geht nicht um eine Fachprüfung, sondern Fachsprache. Das haben Sie. Das Vokabular haben Sie sehr gut, finde ich.
Wenn so ein Patient in die Ambulanz kommt, mit akuten, starken Kopfschmerzen,
dann würde ich das, was der eine Kollege eben auch gleich fragte, ich würde als allererstes die Anamnese unterbrechen und würde Vitalzeichen kontrollieren.
Messen Sie den Blutdruck. Das ist erstmal das A und O.
Und wenn der Blutdruck jetzt vergleichsweise normal ist, sagen wir jetzt mal von mir aus ruhig 170, 180 zu 95,
dann erklärt das nicht unbedingt zu einem ganz starken Kopfschmerz, selbst in dem Bereich.
Wenn er höher ist, natürlich muss man das mit ins Betracht ziehen, aber ich würde immer die Vitalwerte kontrollieren.
In diesem Fall den Blutdruck, vielleicht den SBO2 noch gleich dazu.
Wenn es jetzt keine großen kardialen Geschichten gibt, muss man nicht unbedingt Monitor EKG machen, aber es wäre hilfreich.
Das sind zumindest wichtige Dinge, besonders der Blutdruck in diesem Fall.
Den würde ich auf alle Fälle im Anfang messen. Das macht einen guten Eindruck für die Patientin, für Sie selber.
Sie haben eine Information und auch in der Prüfung macht das einen guten Eindruck.
Bei so etwas immer möglichst kurz bei akuten Thoraxschmerzen, bei akuten Kopfschmerzen, möglichst diese Werte gerade messen.
Das dauert nicht lange und Sie können ja sagen, ich unterbreche jetzt hier die Anamnese und messe erstmal die Werte.
Und dann können Sie ruhig sagen, die Werte waren weitgehend unauffällig.
Wenn natürlich jetzt der Blutdruck bei 220, 230 ist, dann muss man sich eben überlegen, diesen Blutdruck schonend zu senken.
Das wissen wir inzwischen nicht radikal.
Und dann haben Sie aber zumindest mehr Informationen.
Sie können sich sicherer sein, dass Sie jetzt die Anamnese fortsetzen können.
Weil sonst wäre das ein Intensivpatient, der überwacht gehört.
Oder dann dürften Sie ihn jetzt nicht fragen, wo sind Sie hin verreist und rauchen Sie, sondern das ist dann nicht mehr wichtig.
Aber gut, denken Sie bitte daran, das ruhig einmal mehr zu machen, als Sie häufig denken.
Es macht einen guten Eindruck.
Das ist gut.
Und es ging jetzt auch nicht darum, die richtige Diagnose zu stellen.
Ich kenne bei der Patientin auch nicht die richtige Diagnose.
Aber ich könnte mir eben denken, dass es eine hypertensive Krise ist und dass es eine Subarachnoidalblutung sein kann.
Hirndruckzeichen, was auch immer.
Der relativ schnelle Beginn, der kann fast auf eine Subarachnoidalblutung hinweisen.
Sie sagt, der Schmerz trat ziemlich plötzlich auf.
Ein Spannungskopfschmerz, was da diskutiert wurde, der in der Regel baut er sich etwas langsamer auf.
Also das geht, es geht innerhalb von ein, zwei Stunden, dass so ein Spannungskopfschmerz so stark werden kann.
Aber eine Blutung ist meistens ein akut Ereignis, was Schmerzen angeht.
Ich hoffe, alle Neurologen, die jetzt zuhören, geben mir recht.
Oder wir können mir auch gerne widersprechen, dass es anders ist.
Aber ich würde das so sagen.
Erstmal von der Einschätzung her.
Aber ich bin zufrieden, Sie haben das gut gemacht.
Ja, normalerweise machen wir es so.
In der Praxis.
Aber die Prüfung, Simulation.
Ja, es ist immer etwas anders.
Es ist immer etwas anders.
Es ist Stress.
Ich habe nur einen Hinweis oder eine Bitte.
Sie haben, das war vielleicht ein Ausdruck von Stress.
In der Schilderung, bei der Vorstellung, haben Sie am Anfang sehr viel Ihre Hand so vor dem Gesicht gehabt.
Und irgendwas gesagt.
Versuchen Sie das nicht.
Lassen Sie die Hände möglichst aus dem Gesicht raus.
Halten Sie die Hände mit einem Kugelschreiber fest oder am Blatt Papier.
Aber es gibt viele Menschen, wenn ich mal Stress habe, dann kratze ich mich gerne hinten am Kopf, am Nacken.
Bei Ihnen war es im Anfang hier vorne mehr.
Versuchen Sie das möglichst nicht.
Gut, ja, erstmal vielen Dank.
Aber ich fand das gut.
Sie haben das gut gemacht.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja.
Bei einer Glakon-Attacke sehen wir einigen Schmerzen einseitig oder?
Ich glaube ja.
Wahrscheinlich schon einseitige Schmerzen.
Das Auge muss aber nicht immer doll gerötet sein, habe ich früher gelernt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es zurzeit ist.
Natürlich wäre eine einseitige Augenrötung hilfreich, wenn ich das beobachte.
Aber ich habe im Augenblick ja nur die Patientin befragt.
Ich habe jetzt noch nicht meine subjektiven Eindruck von...
Also ich habe sie noch nicht inspiziert.
Ich habe sie noch nicht angeschaut.
Ich habe noch nicht die Bulby getastet, ob die Bulby jetzt sehr hart sind oder weich oder wie.
Also die körperliche Untersuchung und Inspektion hat ja noch nicht stattgefunden.
Okay, wenn wir denken, keine Zubereitung der Blutdruckung, keine erhöhte arteriöse Blutdruckung.
Und denken wir einen Glakon-Anfall.
Wir sind gerade im Notfall in Deutschland.
Ein Glakon-Anfall ist ein Notfall, klar.
Rufen wir Augenarzt oder wie sind...
Also wenn Sie daran denken, das ist ein akuter Glakon.
Alles andere ist ausgeschlossen.
Also Sie haben keinen Hinweis auf eine Subarachnoidalblutung.
Der Blutdruck ist in Ordnung, weitgehend unauffällig.
Dann muss es ja etwas anderes sein.
Und dann muss man natürlich bei der Patientin eventuell doch ans Auge denken.
Und dann möglichst vielleicht doch einen Ophthalmologen...
Aber ein Notfallarzt könnte selbst die Glakon messen oder...
Also längst nicht jeder Notarzt misst den Augendruck.
Das ist in Deutschland zumindest, so kenne ich das eher, Aufgabe eines Ophthalmologen.
In der Türke gibt es immer einen Notfallarzt im Krankenhaus.
Aber ich weiß es nicht, in Deutschland auch.
Also in den großen Krankenhäusern gibt es ja auch eine Augenabteilung.
Aber in den vielen kleineren Krankenhäusern oder mittelgroßen ist nicht immer ein Augenarzt da.
Aber es gibt Konsiliärzte.
Wenn Sie den Verdacht haben auf einen akuten Glakon-Anfall...
Und der Patient hat zwar Tropfen, aber Sie kommen nicht weiter so.
Dann müssen Sie diesen Konsiliärzt notfallmäßig hinzuziehen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, stressbedingte Hypertonie sehe ich da unten wegen Glakon an alle.
Ja, kann sein.
Und hat die Patientin gesagt, dass sie ein ruhiges Leben führt.
Sie ist als Programmiererin glücklich.
Sie sagt, sie hat keinen Stress.
Das ist subjektiv.
Natürlich kann es auch irgendwas anderes sein.
Ein akuter Ereignis, ein Trauma, seelischer Art, was auch immer.
Das weiß ich jetzt aber nicht.
Wir sehen uns, wenn Sie wollen, nächste Woche wieder am Donnerstag.
Und dann wünsche ich Ihnen jetzt einen schönen Abend.
Das hat mir Spaß gemacht. Machen Sie es gut. Tschüss.
Vielen Dank.